so guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today is going to be about the
execution or some of the characters you
know some executions most of the moveset
that got leaked and whatnot are not
leaked but we're shown in the dead
stream so Ubisoft don't copyright me
this was from your stream so it's
basically going to be about the majority
of the video and then the last portion
is going to be about the copyright
strike situation just a little bit of an
update really but it's just going to be
a very small part toward the end so if
you're only here for the characters
that's completely fine I understand it
but that's going to be first so let's
not keep you guys waiting so the first
character though is gladiator gladiator
has multiple chain attacks and one that
requires four light attacks to complete
the whole chain but he also has a couple
unblockable moves one being a deflect
move and one of them being a what's
called skewer in the chant used in
chains attack which allows them to stab
the enemy and cause a little bit of
bleed damage this is also used to end
the chain in any combo he has just like
the four light attack ones you can do
for lights and then end it with the
skewer in chain to get lots of damage
pull off now I don't know how exactly
this is going to be like useful because
once again no one can really throw all
four lights unexpectedly like use then
you land all of them so we'll have to
figure out how that works either way
this is going to be very interesting
gladiator also has a parry punish or
drains lots of stamina the gladiators
main objective is basically to strain to
drain your stamina and then destroy it
with fast light attacks so that's going
to be about him then and then now we
move on to Highlander Highlander has two
stances like I've stated previously the
offensive and defensive stances which
look like this the difference is that
the offensive stance has a glow and his
sword kind of like conkers flow when he
starts to hold the right trigger and
just swing it around that's the only
difference between the two and that is
in offensive mode he is a lot of slow
but very damaging attacks and can even
feint those attacks into superfast
lights here's a lot of interesting
unblockable as well like a kick cancel
into a grab or a heavy attack cancel
into a kick and then cancel that into a
grab so huge bundle of unblockable and
fainting attacks live for a decent
amount of mix-ups and once again this is
he's going to be very hard character to
master it will be very rewarding though
once you understand his moveset
so it
kinda hard to judge whether these
characters are going to be good or not I
believe that the gladiator has probably
way too many unlockables for a character
is about 7 or 8 and then Highlander is
about the same with about maybe four or
five unblockable I believe so they have
a pretty interesting move set there's a
lot of things with these characters they
need to master but I feel like there has
to there might be a change coming soon
because I feel like this many
unblockable is going to cause some
controversy
once again characters aren't out yet
we'll have to wait so we'll just get
onto that then if you're all you want to
see is the characters that's just about
it there's going to be guides game
playing streams with these characters by
the way so if you are looking interested
in that please stay subscribed but
either way I'm gonna continue on the
next topic so now the characters are
done I want to talk about the copyright
strike situation so far first off thank
you all for guys for the great comments
on that video it was really heartwarming
I'm trying to get it sorted out
hopefully they'll answer but so far I
haven't gotten an answer from Ubisoft
but what bothers me though is that two
other youtubers not going to name names
or anything it's not like I'm hating on
them but they did videos on the
Highlander and gladiator moveset prior
not prior but before the characters were
released like how I did and they haven't
received a claim or a strike and they
even showed the screenshots just like I
did so I'm not saying I want them to get
destroyed because I would never want
someone to get a copyright strike but it
just doesn't make sense to me that video
also was the one with the foreigner
amino app part so I'm wondering if that
had might have had something to do with
it
I don't really know I'm still trying to
figure out what's going on I'm just
waiting on Ubisoft to give me a response
because it's all I'm really waiting for
either way it doesn't matter though that
much to me she got to move past it and
just not [ __ ] up again either way this
sounds bad but there's some good out of
it there's always good that comes out of
a bad situation
and in this situation we passed over
2000 subscribers you guys as I'm looking
at it we have about 2014 that's
incredibly amazing thank you all I had
about 1700 subs just three days ago and
then now with these recent videos coming
out were just blowing up on the channel
so shout out once again to all the new
subs all you old subs love you all and
like I said my most recent videos are
going to be popping up on the screen
just in case you have missed those
Vivat if you did enjoy subscribe for
more on our content such as like I said
the guides the gameplay and the streams
of the new characters coming in the
future hope you guys will enjoy those
when they come out and I'll see you guys
the next upload peace out